for more information on tutoring or how
to support moofy university and the
production of more videos please visit
moof university com thank you and enjoy
so we mentioned that solving
Schrodinger's equation gives many
possible wave functions or orbitals
atomic orbitals and each of these is
described by a set of three quantum
numbers three quantum numbers and these
quantum numbers are according to a
hierarchy what that means is that the
subsequent contem numbers are dependent
on those before them now you'll notice a
little aster asterisk here at the three
four quantum numbers and the reason why
that's there is because we'll talk about
a fourth one later but here it's the
reason why I put three here and we'll
talk about the fourth one later is
because the first three quantum numbers
describe the actual orbital or orbitals
whereas the fourth one does not the
fourth one describes the electron
specifically so we'll get to that later
so the first quantum number is the
principal quantum number represented by
the letter n lowercase n the principal
quantum number is a positive integer so
that means we're starting with N equals
one and we can go n equals to n equals
three and equals four so on and so forth
now the principal quantum number is
related to the size and energy of the
orbital so as n increases the energy
increases why is that well as n
increases the orbital size increases
which means that the electron is more
likely to be further away from the
nucleus and electron is attracted to the
nucleus positively the nucleus is
positively charged electrons are
negatively charged they are attracted to
each other the electrons are further
away if n is larger and that's not a
position the electrons want to be and
right that's not favorable they don't
want to be away from the positive charge
they want to be closer so because
they're not kind of where they want to
be then
the energy level is higher okay so the
principle quantum number if we're
talking I the quinta quantum number N
equals 1 or n equals 2 we can also refer
to them as energy levels so energy level
1 or the first energy level with a
second energy level third energy level
we can also think about them being
called shells the first shell second
shell third shell so if you see those
terms that's kind of what they're
referring to the second quantum number
is the angular momentum quantum number
represented by a lowercase L so for a
given end value it's an important part
here for given l value n value excuse me
for a given L n value all integers from
0 to n minus 1 are the possible L values
ok so the fact that it has for a given n
value that means that the L quantum
number value is dependent on the n value
are the possible L values are dependent
on the end that you're talking about so
for example if you have n equals 1 what
are your possible L values will use the
start at zero all right so 0 is a
possible value the next value would be
number would be one right but you're
limited the maximum is n minus 1 what's
N 1 1 minus one is zero so that means
one is not a is not an actual possible
value so the only L value possible for N
equals 1 is 0 whereas for N equals to
start at zero and one is actually
possible because n minus 1 is 1 so that
that that value is possible but it's the
last possible value you can imagine that
for N equals 3 be possible L values are
0 1 and 2 for 4 for N equals 4 you'd
have 0 1 2 3 all right so on and so
forth now the angular momentum quantum
number L is related to the shape
the orbital okay and it's often referred
to as the energy sub level because it
also relates to some extent to energy or
the sub shell alright so we're n
describes the energy level and the show
l describes the energy sub level or sub
show okay each value of L has a
corresponding letter which we can see
here to the right value of l and its
corresponding letter so 0 if you have an
l equals 0 the corresponding letters s
you have a value of one that's p 2 is
the 3f four is g5 and onward actually
four and onward is just an alphabetical
order so there's six of the eye and
further jkl just alphabetically but we
normally won't worry about anything past
f so in fact I don't think we're ever
going to go past that okay so the reason
why that's important is that each letter
corresponds to a different shape right
that's kind of how this and this going
right shape is sort of determined by the
letter and we'll see that in more detail
on the next video so the third quantum
number the magnetic quantum number M sub
L that is dependent on the quantum
number before it which is l so it's
possible values are all the integers
from negative L through zero to positive
al so for l equals 1 for instance the M
sub L values start at negative else so
that be negative 1 and then we go to in
the positive direction to all the
different possible values so we have
negative 1 the next one would be 0 and
then we're live we go to positive 1 so
the possible M sub L values are negative
L negative 1 all the way to positive
positive one so for l equals 2 we'd have
negative 2 negative 1 0 1 and positive 2
now the magnetic quantum number M sub L
is related to the orientation of the
orbital the orientation of the orbital
in 3d space so each M sub L value
represents a separate orbital separate
orbital and orbitals can be represented
as lines boxes or circles that can be
filled with electrons which are
designated by arrows will see that more
later and I'll kind of show you what's
going on here so each of these M sub L
value is negative 1 0 and positive 1 or
have a corresponding orbital which I've
represented here despite lines that you
can fill with arrows and each for battle
can have a maximum of two electrons in
it so if i were to completely fill these
I'd fill these like this if one electron
going up there up up and then electron
going down down and each of these arrows
represents an electron why are these
arrows and Wise Ones pointing up and one
pointing down in each of these and why
did I fill them in that way that I did
that's all stuff that will learn more
about later so let's kind of go through
a little summary of what's going on with
these values so if N equals 1 what are
the possible L values it's just 0 ok I'd
encourage you to try to do this on your
own before going through this in detail
maybe try to like pause the video and
guess kind of what we come up come up
next so this L has a corresponding
letter and and zeroes corresponding
letter is s so the orbital notation is
given as n L so here we have 1 and 0
corresponds to ask the orbital notation
would be 1 s or to be possible M sub L
values well it would just be 0 right
because depending on el L is 0 so it's
just 0 the number of orbitals in this in
this s subshell is just this one M sub L
value right so that's just one okay the
total number of orbitals in that she'll
is just one because it's the only sub
shell
and there's only one shell so what's the
maximum electron capacity if each of
these orbitals can have two electrons
the max that this one can have is two so
if the n value is equal to two the
possible L values are 0 and 1 if you
have the L value of zero you have the
orbital notation would be 2s if you have
it for N and N equals 2 and l equals 1
the orbital notation would be to pee the
2p orbital so how many 2's orbitals do
we have just one and it's ms l value is
zero all right we only have 1 2 s
orbital but we'll get to that value in
just a second what about to pee how many
2p orbitals do we have well the possible
M sub L value is for l equals 1 or
negative 10 and positive one so that's
three orbitals in that sub shell in that
P sub show so the total number of
orbitals in this shell and the N equals
2 shell is one plus three which is four
okay and if we have four total orbitals
in this shell what's the maximum
electronic capacity in this N equals 2
shell of four orbitals two electrons eh
that'll be eight okay 43 we could have
the possible L values as zero one and
two for talking about 3 and 0 that would
be the 3s orbital three and one would be
the 3p orbital 32 would be describing 3d
orbitals so how many at 3s or Bros we
have 0 how many 3p orbitals do we have 3
negative 1 0 and positive 1 how many 3d
orbitals do we have well what are the
possible M sub L is for two we have
negative 2 negative 1 0 positive 1
positive 2 so how many orbitals are
going to these sub shells the SP and d
sub shells you got one three and five if
we add those up we get a total of nine
total orbitals in that she'll each of
those can hold two electrons so that's a
maximum electron capacity of 18 so i'm
going to i'm just going to reveal the
values for four and hopefully you can
think through them so we can see this
going on here
just going to reveal them so that you
can see what's going on and you should
reason your way through them on your own
okay what I want you to notice is that
the number of orbitals in the sub shell
will be equal to 2 l plus 1 so if you
know the certain l value you plug it
into this formula you will get that
value so if you have for instance 30
right if you have l equals 0 you'll have
two times zero plus one which is zero
plus one which is one if you have two
two times two is four plus 1 is 5 so
that will give you the number of
orbitals in that sub show how do you get
the total number of overdose in that
show that's just N squared right the
shell is is the N value and you just
take that number square it and that's
the total number of orbitals in that
she'll and you'll notice that it with
maximum electron capacity is just two
times that so that would be equal to 2n
squared so those up there are kind of
helpful things to keep in mind when
you're thinking about what's going on
with these different energy levels and
shells sub shells and how many orbitals
there are in each of these then these
orbital notations ok so again this is
all so far just the orbitals we're
talking about the fourth quantum number
which describes electron spin and is
denoted as M sub s will be described
later so I hope that video was helpful
thank you for watching if you found that
video helpful don't forget to Like
comment subscribe and share with friends
thank you and happy studying